I want to talk about something which I
claim happened before the Big Bang now
you see this represents a change of mind
on my part
which used to think like Stephen Hawking
in many people that the Big Bang didn't
have any before because the notion of
before and after didn't mean anything
when there wasn't a universe around and
so you couldn't even talk about before
well I'm going back on that and I claim
that there is something before but
before getting to that let me describe
the universe the second law of
thermodynamics says that this thing
called entropy which increases as you go
as time increases and thing is that we
see in the universe observational II but
it looks as though the entropy is very
very high at the beginning which should
be very low because it has to start low
how is it low it's low in gravity which
means that the universe with me I don't
really want to go into that argument
even started early because it because
it's key to the description but it will
distract me too much for what I want to
say I just say there's good reason for
saying that this can be stretched out
it's very nice it solves a lot of
problems if that is the way the universe
for some reason stretched out like that
what's the reason well here's what I'm
saying the reason is is because this our
universe as we think of it starting from
the Big Bang ending up with this eternal
exponential expansion going on and on
and on getting you more and more borings
as time goes on and the argument is that
that our universe as we serve as we
thought it's not the whole story that
this future remember the Escher picture
can be stretched squash down and now it
becomes the Big Bang of the next Ayana
and so this is what I call consort
conformal cyclic cosmology that we are
here there was one of these eons I'm
calling him an eel and I looked up in
the dictionary to make sure an eon aeo n
was not an actual length of time it
seems to be a while it's a long time but
not
lenka time which is fine by me so I've
used that term here a cosmic Eon is that
but I'm claiming there was a cosmic eon
preceding us one later than the last one
preceding before and so on and they just
continue indefinitely now you see you
might say well it's a bit hard to
swallow and that's what lots of people
say it's hard to swallow
because isn't the remote future very
very different from a Big Bang well
first of all it's very very rarefied it
gets very the density goes down and down
and down they're done it's extremely
cold the temperature goes down and down
and down what's the big bang light
density is huge
the temperature is enormous but you see
when you do this transformation which
with the I did with the angels and
devils that conform was squashing or
stretching it makes big tip when you
stretch it then big temperatures go down
and the densities go down when you
squash it the temperatures go up and the
densities go up and they match so
they're physically match as well as
geometrically matching for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute's of arson ideas at IAI TV
you